i need five people quickly any
volunteers
the man says
they form a line to unload donated food
water bedding clothes it's taken into
what for decades has been a center for
culture and arts and has now become a
vital and potential life-saving aid
distribution point
there's an incredible sense of purpose
and energy in this center what these
people are doing is they're taking in
donations of food
clothing bedding medicine
they're boxing them up
boxing the materials up and then they're
going to be distributing them to many of
the hundreds of thousands of people that
have fled the fighting
across this region
it's much better than sitting at home we
are as depressed as everyone in the
country but we come here to lift our
spirits we feel proud and unified here
volunteers stick tape on the windows in
an effort to stop shards of glass being
blown into the building if shells land
nearby
a piece of history is being offered as a
place where people can hide
so it's been 20 years since this soviet
built cinema was used
and now volunteers are offering it as a
place where people can come and shelter
from the shelling
if
we heard some blows explosions
we gave to people instructions to open
mouths
and to hold hands
and put like like this
there's a basement where people can also
take shelter
upstairs the sorting the packing the
distribution continues as this city
prepares for the worst
charles stratford al jazeera denipro